Das größte rätsel der physik ist wohl wie sich
teilchenphysik und gravitation in einem modell vereinen lassen dabei helfen könnte die mathematische struktur der league gruppe r8 sie hat
besondere symmetrie eigenschaften und könnte eine einheitliche theorie in der für sich arbeitet quasi die
theorie von allem also die weltformel schlechthin ein super aufregendes und mister großes thema dass er mir über whatsapp
vorgeschlagen habe danke dafür und herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende science videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr kein video
Alle vorgänger und zustände im universum sollen sich mit ihr beschreiben lassen von den kleinsten dingen im quanten bereich bis zu den größten
kosmischen strukturen überhaupt rund 1 us physiker behauptet tatsächlich
diese formel aufgestellt zu haben was kann diese
angebliche weltformel wirklich und was steckt dahinter schon in den 60er jahren hatten physiker und physikerinnen
herausgefunden dass sich
elementarteilchen mit ihren
unterschiedlichen eigenschaften
wie masse und ladung in eine bestimmte ordnung bringen lassen das sind die sogenannten lee gruppen also vereinfacht gesagt
strukturen in der mathematik die über besondere symmetrie eigenschaften verfügen
mit den einfacheren gruppen können objekte wie kegel oder zylinder beschrieben werden auch wenn sie gedreht werden
sehen sie gleich aus bei der sogenannten g8 struktur ist das anders sie ist viel komplexer
insgesamt umfasst sie
248 dimensionen und damit sind nicht etwa raumdimensionen gemeint sondern
freiheitsgrade also die
variablen eines systems mit deren größten änderungen sich auch die komplette struktur verändert mit ihrer hilfe haben
forschungsteams dann im laufe der zeit das standardmodell der
elementarteilchenphysik entwickelt konkret besteht es aus der kombi von insgesamt drei
gruppen in denen alle bekannten elementarteilchen und drei der fundamental kräfte
berücksichtigt sind doch eine wichtige sache fehlt die
gravitation also die schwerkraft lange ging man davon aus dass sich dieses problem im laufe der zeit von alleine lösen würde eben durch die
entdeckung
die gruppe die auch die gravitation nicht ausschließt doch das
passierte nicht und durch andere ideen für eine einheitliche theorie der physik rückte de 8 theorie in den hintergrund 2007
machte sie jedoch wieder schlagzeilen und zwar durch den forscher anthony garrett ließ von der universität in san diego
erfüllte die acht struktur mit verschiedenen bekannten teilchen und kräften den 20 unbesetzten punkten ordnete er dann
hypothetische teilchen zu in einer computersimulation ließ er dann die struktur
rotieren die muster ergebnisse zeigen an wie die zeichen und kräfte möglicherweise
wechselwirken das krasse daran diese stimmen mit den messergebnissen in der realen welt bereit so lieh sie in diesem moment explodierte
mein gehirn als ich die implikation und die schönheit dieses ding sei ich dachte heiliger bimbam das ist es
beispielsweise
lagerten sich quarks um grawe elektro magnetische teilchen und zwar in familien von den drei partikeln mit jeweils denselben eigenschaften
aber anderen massen genau so beschreibt auch das standardmodell diese partikel wie sie
veröffentlichte sein ergebnis unter dem titel eine
außergewöhnliche theorie von allem ganz besonders stellte liese heraus dass sein modell ohne strings auskommen und es so
einfach und schön sei jedenfalls ist sich sicher
dass das universum auf reiner geometrie beruht doch eines steht noch aus und zwar der endgültige experimentelle beweis oder zumindest
handfeste hinweise auf seine theorie beispielsweise wäre das gegeben wenn der large hadron collider
bei genf im cern diejenigen 20 partikel aufspüren könnte mit der lhi seine struktur aufgefüllt hatte
kleinere indizien für die u18 metro wurden in einem experiment dagegen bereits entdeckt ein forschungsteam aus oxford
hatte kristalle aus niob und kobalt abgekühlt und zwar auf 0,4 grad über dem absoluten nullpunkt die atome
lagerten sich zu langen ketten und die elektronen verhielten sich wie kleine
stabmagneten und zwar aufgrund ihres spins also eine art re im polster teilchen und aufgrund dessen
bildete sich dann spontan ein muster als das forscherteam
das magnetfeld rechtwinklig zu den spinnen achsen anbrachte die überraschung war groß als man entdeckte dass sich die spins gemäß der
symmetrie angeordnet hatten warum genau und was dahinter steckt das ist noch ein großes rätsel aufregend ist aber schon dass
eben nicht nur ein
mathematisches konstrukt ist sondern tatsächlich auch in der echten welt zu finden ist und noch ein wort zur
stringtheorie die durch ihren glanz das g8 modell lange in den schatten gestellt hatte einige physiker und physikerinnen
jedenfalls sind der ansicht dass das g8 modell
des trink theorie gar nicht widerspricht sondern sie nur ergänzt werden ja einmal ausführlich über die stringtheorie berichtet bei der die
elementarteilchen je nach schwingungs zustand verschiedene eigenschaften annehmen sie schließt im gegensatz zum eher 8 modell die
gravitation nicht aus allerdings bezieht sich die schwingungen der strings auf bis zu 21
raumdimensionen je nach modell beide formel zusammen jedenfalls würden die
relativität und quantentheorie zu einer vereinen zu einer weltformel der quantengravitation doch dazu muss noch einiges passieren denn für die stringtheorie
existiert noch kein extrem teller beweis aber dafür gibt es ja auch einen hinweis in unserem video zum thema
existiert unser universum mit string theorie bald bewiesen dafür hier draufklicken und auch darunter unbedingt drauf klicken
da geht es nämlich zu unserem neuen englischen blick zum science und fiction kanal
draufklicken und abonnieren wenn er mich auf englisch sehen wollt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran